YINNON HAVIV: Hi everybody.
Welcome.
I'd like to start this session
with a small video that kind
of inspired us into pursuing
this topic.
So watch closely.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[TECHNO MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
YINNON HAVIV: Pretty
cool, huh?
So my name is Yinnon, I lead
a team that does the Google
Chart Tools and together with me
is Michael Fink, the PM for
that same team.
And what we are going to talk
about today is how to turn
your data into a story.
The structure of this session
will contain two parts.
So in the first part, we'll take
the data, and we'll show
you how to create a dashboard
over this data that allows you
to watch the data from different
perspectives.
Each perspective, each slice,
will show up a little bit
different information.
And the graph that you see below
here is the different
possibilities to go from
one slice into another.
And you will give this dashboard
to your user.
And that dashboard can be used
to travel the data and slice
and dice the data, moving
freely in this graph.
In the second part of the talk,
we'll show you how to
make a story out of
that same data.
And that story will resemble a
path inside this graph that
we've seen earlier.
And so without further delays,
let's move and start with the
first part.
So the first part is all about
how to create dashboards that
allow you to explore your
data, explore it freely.
To explore data I need
to start with data.
So the data that we chose today,
we wanted to start with
the topic of the popularity
of specific artists.
And if you ask people how to
measure the popularity of
artists, of performers,
you would get--
if you ask five persons you
would get around seven
different answers.
So if you ask Michael Fink,
who is also the product
manager for Google Insights
and Google Trends, he will
tell you one answer.
And that would be use the
search popularity.
Just consider how many times
people have searched for
Beyonce, in this example, or
how many times people have
searched for Madonna.
And that would give you some
sort of a measurement of how
popular Madonna and
Beyonce are.
And you can do that for
every single month or
every single day.
We chose the month
granularity.
And you can do it for every
country in the world, and for
every performer as we just
discussed, and you would get a
measurement that shows
the popularity.
The number doesn't
mean anything.
Just a comparison between
those numbers mean
everything you like.
So you can see here that in the
United States in December,
2008, Beyonce was much more
popular than Madonna.
And what we did is we extracted
this data from 2004
until now for all
the countries.
Actually I'm sure we did
less than that but
for most of the countries.
And for several performers we
extracted this information.
And that's the information
that we are
going to be using today.
So to be able to see parts of
this data, we will need some
sort of a way to slice and
dice this data, or limit
ourselves to viewing only
parts of that data.
So what we have here
are controls.
The first control will allow
us to focus on a specific
period of time.
So now I'm watching the period
of time starting at January
2009, and let's take it all the
way to the end of 2009.
And I can move this control.
The table that you see over
here, the data inside of that
table changes.
So I can control the time.
And in the same sense I have
controls that allow me to pick
those countries that
I want to watch.
So currently I am watching
the information only
from the US and UK.
And I can add in any country
that I like.
I'm from Israel, so I'll
add in Israel.
And I can do that for the
set of performers.
So you can see here the
set of performers that
I picked for you.
From Adele, Beyonce, Christina
Aguilera, Jennifer Lopez,
Justin Timberlake,
and Madonna.
So that would be the performers
that we'll be
looking at today.
And I can move those controls
and the data table changes.
And I'll see now it's
Beyonce and Madonna.
And I see the US, the UK, and
Israel as I requested.
So it turns out that creating
such a dashboard is quite easy
using the Google Chart Tools.
How many of you are using
the Google Chart Tools?
Have been using it?
Quite a lot.
How many of you were here last
year in the talk that we gave?
So for most of you,
it will be new.
What we showed last year
is how to create those
dashboards.
So I'm going to go pretty
quickly on that.
But if you want more details,
you can look at the lecture.
You can watch the lecture,
it is recorded.
So dashboards are quite easy.
Most of our libraries, most of
the libraries that we made, we
tried to make it as
easy as we can.
We tried for the programmer
to do the minimal coding
required to set up.
So the dashboard is
no different.
All you need to do to create a
dashboard is to create this
dashboard object that will be
controlling your different
controls and visualizations
in the dashboard.
So we are setting up
this dashboard.
And then we are setting each
of the controls, the time
picker control, the country
picker control, and the
performer picker control.
And each of our visualizations.
In this case we have only a
table visualization, so that's
the table chart over here.
In some sense each of those--
if you know the library, you
know what charts are--
each of those wrappers wrapped
together the chart with a
specific preset of
configuration.
So the table chart is all about
picking up a chart, a
chart of a specific type, table,
and stating up ahead
what will be the options that
you will be using and how do
you want to view this
data in the table.
But the magic happens here.
Here we give those controls
and visualizations to the
dashboard and we chain
them together in
some information flow.
So we take the output of the
time picker control and we
squeeze that into the country
picker control.
If you remember the time is
first, then the country, and
then we have the performer.
So we take the output of the
time picker control, squeeze
that into the country picker,
and the country piker into the
performer picker.
From the performer picker we
take the output, and we put it
into the table chart.
And the reason that you see
erase over there is that you
can take the data from one
control and push it into many
of visualizations and vice
versa in some sense.
So once you're done with that,
all you need to do is draw
your dashboard with the data
that you want to push.
[COUGHS].
Sorry about that.
OK.
So I tried to make the code
snippet from the previous
slide easy to read.
So I removed all the details,
but there are details and
people would want to customize
their controls.
If you think about it, a time
picker control, you might want
to customize the initial range
that you will be showing.
So in this case, we are showing
a range from November
2008 to March 2009.
That's the initial range
that we are using.
And you might want
to customize--
the minimal amount of time
spent at the control will
allow the user to
physically grab.
We have a whole bunch
of configurations
for each of the controls.
It's the same as we do for
the visualizations.
We follow the different
requests and create
flexibility to handle those.
So watching the data
using a data table
doesn't help us a lot.
It kind of dumps the
data on top of us.
And what I want to do is I want
to use visualizations to
actually show the data.
If you look at the data that I'm
currently showing in the
table, it has several different
times, several
different countries, and several
different performers.
So it's kind of hard to show
all of that in the same
visualization.
If I'm willing to reduce one
of the dimensions, for
example, the time dimension,
I can show a bar chart.
Right?
Once I focused on a specific
date, December 2008, I'm left
with four data points, the
popularity of Beyonce and
Madonna in the US and the UK.
OK.
And I'm able to show a bar chart
that compares the two.
And of course I can add
in more information.
And still, the bar chart will be
useful because I'm able to
compare the differences
states.
And I'm able to see, for
example, that the gap between
Beyonce and Madonna
in the US is huge.
But in India, it's
not like that.
OK?
So it's quite useful to use a
bar chart for this situation.
But if I'm reducing myself to
one country, for example the
US, I don't need a bar chart.
I can still use a bar chart, but
I don't need a bar chart.
I can use a much cleaner
visualization such as a pie
chart or a donut chart,
in this case.
It's the same.
So if I'm reducing another
dimension, I can go and use a
more simple visualization.
If I reduce another
dimension--
let's reduce the performer
dimension.
OK so now I have four data
points that I have to present.
But if I'm reducing another
dimension, how many lines
would I have left in my table?
Probably one, right?
So showing one line is all about
showing just the number.
I can still move the
dashboard around.
And I can still see that gauge
changing from one value to
another, but it's going to be
one value at each time.
So I feel a little bit that this
space in my slide is not
being used very efficiently.
I can see a lot of time in the
same visualization, right?
I can now watch the period that
I just showed, and I can
see the popularity of Beyonce
in the United States
throughout this period.
I can even compare different
artists in the same slide.
There is no reason for me
to just show Beyonce.
I can compare them
all together.
And I can't even compare
states together.
I can just put in Croatia and
see, throughout this period
that I picked, I can see how the
popularity of Beyonce is
different in those different
states that I just picked.
You know what?
I want to try to view all the
countries all together.
And to do that I'm going to
remove this filter altogether.
So I'm going to show all
the countries in one
visualization.
That's going to be quite
horrible, right?
It's quite hard to watch.
But if I were to reduce the time
that I'm looking at into
one month, a specific month,
that we will be watching, I
can view all this information
very clearly on a geographical
chart, a geochart.
So that's how I can do that.
Let's say I looked at this
information, and I figured
that the difference between
the different states, it
doesn't matter for my story.
It doesn't give me
any insight.
So let's just average
around that.
Let's just look at the
world as a whole.
Once I reduce this country
dimension I'm again free to
explore my data, I'm free
to take a look at more
information.
And essentially I reduced
one of the dimensions.
So I'm left with visualizing
the two other dimensions.
I can do the same averaging
for the dates.
And I can add more performers.
And now I'm looking at
performance of those artists
throughout the duration of 2008,
because I'm averaging
over the period of 2008 I
think that being a good
performer is about being
consistent and being searched
a lot throughout a big
period of time.
So I'm looking at the entire
period of 2008.
So what we are seeing here is
that for each of the different
domains that we have, the time,
the country, and the
performer, we have several
possibilities.
We can pick one value, or we
can pick several values.
We can aggregate over
those values.
We chose to average around those
values, but we could've
used other aggregation methods
when it suits.
And we can do that
independently
for each of the domains.
So we are left with this cube of
possibilities, and it's an
exponential number in
the number of domain
columns that we have.
And this data that we have right
here only contains one
metric, the popularity metric.
We could have had several of
those metrics and we could
have used different
visualizations.
And all this combination of
possibilities is hard because
just throwing that kind of a
dashboard onto your user, it's
impossible to navigate.
It's not impossible, but it's
kind of letting him solve the
problem on his own.
And what you really want to
do is you want to walk him
through the story of those
performers instead of just
throwing the information
at him.
So with that I give you Michael,
who will we be
showing you how to tell a story
using that same data.
MICHAEL FINK: Thank
you, Yinnon.
So I think the state that you
are all currently in is what
doctors call data vertigo.
OK?
You've seen slices and dices of
this data and that was only
three dimensions in one matrix,
probably the simplest
data that one could explore.
And Yinnon demonstrated very
nicely I think that there's an
exponential number of
possibilities in exploring
that data cube.
And for each of those individual
slices that he
showed, he only showed
one visualization.
But often there are several
visualizations
that you could show.
So as Yinnon said, what we would
like to have, in certain
cases, a way to walk our users,
not inflict all of the
data cube on them, but rather
walk them through a very
carefully curated path of slices
that tells a story.
And that's what this part will
be about, telling the story.
Now when we are trying to think
how to tell a story we
could essentially address a
challenge that people have
been addressing for several
thousands of years.
And we thought it would be
nice to go back to the
classical three act play
I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with.
I think this was suggested
back in ancient Greece.
And the three act play
essentially says, if you want
to tell a story, start
with Act One.
That should essentially present
the characters that
are in this story, the
protagonist, the antagonist.
Establish the time and
space where this
story is taking place.
And Act One usually ends
with the conflict, with
establishing the conflict.
What is the grand challenge that
the protagonist has to
address throughout the story?
Then Act Two, which is usually
kind of the main bulk of the
story, are the different
attempts of the main character
to try to address that conflict,
address the grand
challenges that he
must overcome.
Often the big conflict
is derived into
many smaller conflicts.
And then in Act Three
reach the climax.
Where if it's a comedy,
a positive story.
If things have not gone so well
to the protagonist until
this point, but suddenly there's
a positive twist and
we all feel that suspense and
suddenly we all could relax
that things have a happy end.
If it's a tragedy, it's usually
the other way around.
Things seem to improve in Act
Two and then in Act Three when
the climax comes in, something
dramatic happens, something
tragic happens and things
take a turn to the bad.
Now when you see this in Google
I/O, you're probably
wondering, why am I listening
to the three act play in
Google I/O?
And what we try to do as a
team is to address this
challenge of taking these
principles and trying to see
how could these help us with our
data based storytelling.
So we created a concrete
story that we
wanted to tell you about.
And the name of the story is
"Reaching for the Stars." And
this is data driven
storytelling.
So the first thing I want to
do in Act One, here's the
opening Act, is establish
space.
OK, where are we?
Where is this story happening?
So what we're going to do in
this story, we're going to try
to show the success of
different performers.
And we wanted to think of what
would be a good benchmark to
say, this performer is
definitely successful if he's
able to pass this threshold.
And this is the threshold
that we found.
And we chose this threshold
very carefully.
We were trying to think of a
topic that humanity has been
interested in for thousands
and thousands of years.
And we thought, what would be
a good term to plug into
Google Trends to see
interests that have
been around for while?
And we said, well humanity
has been interested
in God for a while.
So we said, OK let's just type
in God in Google Trends and we
get this line and that's just
how many people, every month,
have essentially typed the word
God into Google Search.
And we thought, that would be
a very interesting threshold
because this is definitely
a very well
established point of interest.
And what I'm going to do now,
sorry, is I'm going to try to
show a few performers, and
you'll see them in the context
of this threshold.
So let's take a look at
Justin Timberlake.
So even in the height of his
success Justin Timberlake is
getting close but he's
not quite there.
What about Christina Aguilera?
So Christina Aguilera, four
Grammys, again she has her
ups, she has her downs, but
she's never quite able to pass
that very high threshold that
we set a second ago.
J.Lo.
OK so J.Lo sold over 55 million
albums throughout her
history but still way below that
threshold that we set a
minute ago.
So this is kind of establishing
space.
I think you understand
where we were going.
And now what I want to do is
establish time and zoom back
in time back to 2004 and present
our protagonist, the
main hero of our
story, Madonna.
Now I'm a big, big fan of
Madonna all the way back from
the time I was probably
in the second grade.
So she's been around, what?
For 20-something years.
And Guinness World Records
declared Madonna as the top
selling female recording
artist of all time.
But at 2004 the career was
around for about 20 years and
a lot of people were thinking,
Madonna's not someone we will
be hearing about much
in the future.
But me and several other
dedicated fans we knew that
something big was coming.
And in 2004 indeed Madonna was
working on a big new album and
look what happened next.
"Confessions on a Dance Floor,"
came out and did an
amazing thing.
It was able to pass, in one
month, to pass that amazing
threshold that we
set earlier on.
So all of our local fan club
is obviously celebrating.
And while Madonna reached this
a phenomenal success other
actors or other performers were
out there and trying to
replicate this success.
And here I'm introducing the
antagonist of the story.
So we have here Beyonce.
Completely different generation
of performer.
And Beyonce split from her band,
Destiny's Child, and
emerged as a superstar with her
disc "B-Day." And I really
remember this as a tragic day
when I saw Beyonce pass my
beloved Madonna in
Google search.
And going on to receive five
nominations, five Grammy
nominations.
And we're pretty much at
the end of Act One.
We presented the different
characters in our story, we
presented time, we presented
space and obviously the
conflict is there.
And Madonna in the Rock Hall
of Fame competing with the
next generation of performers
that are emerging.
And now we're entering
Act Two.
So what happens at the beginning
of Act Two, Madonna
tries to recuperate.
Releases "Hard Candy," which
was, I have to admit, not one
of her best records.
But still gaining
some momentum.
And then, Sticky & Sweet, which
was really an amazing
tour worldwide.
That was an awesome tour.
But Beyonce quickly recovers,
releases three consecutive
number one hits in the
United States.
And the divorce of Madonna from
Guy Ritchie definitely
did not help in this
point in time.
And even her compilation disc
that came out later did not
help Madonna and recover from
where she was later on.
Beyonce goes and he wins the
MTV Video Music Award and a
few months later, she gets a
world record of six Grammys in
one evening.
And I think that the peak was
when in the recent VMA stage,
Beyonce announced that she's
pregnant and all of the world
is rejoicing and my beloved
Madonna is way behind.
A few months later, she gives
birth, she calls her
daughter Blue Ivy.
And at that point Beyonce is
at an all-time record of
popularity in Google search.
Now what people don't know is
that the next month Madonna is
scheduled to appear
in the Super Bowl.
How many people here have
seen Madonna in the
Super Bowl this year?
Cool, that's nice.
How many people went online and
searched for Madonna after
the Super Bowl?
You did, really?
Cool.
So it's me and you.
So will Madonna be able
to pass Beyonce?
Act Three, suspense, right?
So let's see.
Almost.
Almost was able to pass
Beyonce's declaration of
having Blue Ivy born.
But she was not quite able to
do it and she was definitely
not able to replicate her
historical achievement of
passing that very high
threshold that
we set earlier on.
So this was a story told what
the exact same data that
Yinnon presented earlier on.
It's the same data cube.
But it's a very careful sequence
of slices of data
that are curated in a way that
they get you engage.
You're interested in the story,
you want to know what
happens next.
You relate to the characters and
you try to think what will
be the outcome of the story?
An experience that you don't
have while you're doing data
exploration.
And this is just one
story from the data
cube that Yinnon presented.
There are thousands of
different stories.
Let's take for example another
story that could have been
derived from Yinnon's data.
Adele, releasing "19," a few
months later appearing on
Saturday Night Live, still not
gaining the momentum the she
was hoping for.
But then she wins a Grammy for
the best new artist and
releases "21," which was
her kind of big hit.
And "Someone Like You," becomes
the number one hit in
the United States and look
what happens next.
OK, whoa.
So there is an endless number
of stories that you could
choose across that same data
cube that Yinnon presented
earlier on.
So what we did in the last year,
we tried to think, what
would be the best tools that we
as the Google Chart Tools
could provide you as developers
in order to tell
these types of stories?
And we came up with a few tools
that essentially were
displayed here.
And I'd like to show you through
a few code snippets
that will help you understand
how we build this
presentation.
So the first thing I want to
show, as you see here, a small
summary of what we saw in
the previous slide.
You see Adele, Adele's amazing
achievement in green.
And you see that we have this
effect of graying out both
Madonna and Beyonce.
Saying, at this point of
time, these two data
series are out of scope.
They have that gray shade
indicating that
they're out of scope.
OK?
Another thing that we did here
is we used the visual
semantics of saying, maybe
occasionally at certain time
points you want to have an
informative tool tip that says
in this date and time
something interesting happened.
How do we add this?
So take the same data table
that Yinnon talked about
earlier on.
And imagine that the first
column is time as it was
previously.
And the second column could
include data on Madonna.
But then we add to the data on
Madonna, we add another column
of data which is binary data and
just says, is the previous
series, is it in scope
or out of scope?
Should it be grayed
out or not?
And so let me kind of emphasize
the part here.
So we introduce a new column
into the data table that has a
specific term that
we call a role.
And we give it a role of
indicating whether it's in
scope or out of scope.
And if we want the entire line
to be gray we just give it a
function that just always
returns false.
And that will just
mean that it's
continuously out of scope.
But you could define
certain ranges that
would be out of scope.
So that's one visual semantic
that was applied here to
Madonna and to Beyonce.
A second visual semantic that
we introduced is this notion
of tool tips or rich
tool tips.
This is not launched yet but it
will be launched very soon.
And there, again, you just add
another column of data into
your data table and you put HTML
snippets in that column.
And we will be presenting that
as the tool tip once someone
hovers over that individual
data point.
A second set of tools that
is very important for
storytelling is animations
and smooth transitions.
That helps the user
maintain context.
So we introduced two types
of animations.
One of them I'd like to present
now, which is what we
call the view window
animation.
This is super simple.
Essentially it lets you draw
all of your data on a big
canvas across all of the
time that is needed.
And then you could define
smaller view windows that show
the chart across different
time periods.
So just as a concrete example,
you could see here that we
have a view window defined
from 2004 to 2012.
And then what we could do is,
once this is rendered, if you
want to have a zoom in effect,
we could define a function
that will run, and it will
define a new window that goes
from the beginning of 2005
to the end of 2005.
So we went from there
long range to the
much smaller range.
And the only thing that you
have to provide is the
animation duration.
OK, so you only provide 2000 as
a two second animation, and
we take care of all
of the rest.
So that's kind of the building
blocks that you will be using.
If you want to add a listener
that says, once this zoom
animation finishes I want you to
do another effect, in this
example, pan to 2006, the only
thing that you have to do is
define another function
that goes to 2006.
And we'll take care of
that panning effect.
And just give us the duration
that you want us to do, and we
will take care of that.
So that was roles
and animations.
And so far we heard stories of
superstars trying to reach for
the stars, but when we were
preparing for Google I/O this
year we were thinking about,
what would be another great
example of a story?
And I remember Yinnon and
I were brainstorming for
probably two or three hours.
And we were saying, maybe the
disaster in Fukushima would be
interesting.
Or maybe the Arab Spring if
we want to be a bit more
optimistic.
Maybe we'll take financial
data and we'll give you a
story on financial data.
But then we thought, all
of these stories are--
everything has been
done already.
We want to have something
new, something fresh.
And what we decided to do is to
give you the tools to tell
your own story.
And that's what we're going to
do in the last part of this.
How will we be doing this?
I want you all-- how many
people have laptops?
You all should have laptops,
so open your laptops.
And I want you to type
in that goo.gl.
That's x, w, 9, capital c, 3.
I'll wait a second so your
laptops could come up.
And we're definitely going to
crash Google Spreadsheet
servers in this experiment,
but we'll
give it a shot anyway.
OK so once you typed in
goo.gl/xw9C3, you'll be seeing
a spreadsheet, a bit like the
spreadsheet you have here on
the bottom.
And the first thing I wanted you
to do is to make your own
copy of that spreadsheet.
OK because that's my personal
data and I don't want you to
look into my personal data.
So make a copy of that
spreadsheet, go to
file, make a copy.
Once you make a copy, you'll
notice on the bottom of the
spreadsheets there
are two sheets.
One is called controls
and the other one is
called emails from.
So just make sure that
you return to
the emails from sheet.
OK?
So I'll give you just one
more second to do that.
Perfect.
So you should be seeing a
spreadsheet that looks a bit
like this with your copy.
And then it has two columns.
Two interesting columns, Column
B, and Column C. And in
cell B1 and in cell C1, the
following thing happens.
I wrote they're from me to Dan
and from me, David in C1.
And I just want you to replace
those two names, Dan and
David, with two people
that you know.
OK?
So one of them could be, say, an
old time friend that you've
been in a relationship
for a while with.
And the other one maybe could be
someone that you met in the
last few months.
And what I've done is I wrote a
short app script that takes
what you wrote and cell B1 and
cell B2 and what it will do,
it will go to your
Gmail account.
Don't worry, this is
completely private.
It's your own spreadsheet and
it will go to your own Gmail
account if you give
it permissions.
But keep that in mind and
share with caution.
It will go to your Gmail account
and just populate a
spreadsheet that has month by
month, how many times emails
from you have the word Dan or
David or whatever names that
you introduced.
Once you've done that, you
could click on the Tools.
And within Tools there's
the Script Editor.
And within Script Editor you'll
have a Run button.
So click the Run button
over there.
It will ask you for a sequence
of permissions.
Say yes, yes, yes, if
you're interested.
Feel free to say no if you're
not interested.
And once you finished giving
all of those permissions
you'll have to run it again.
OK, so run it again
I'm optimistic and I'm thinking
that maybe at least
one of you was able to follow
that sequence of instructions.
But this is a cute toy and
you'll be able to play
with it later on.
And once you run that and wait
for, say, 10 or 15 seconds the
app script will go to your Gmail
account, fetch all of
the counts of how many times
that name was mentioned, and
will populate that
spreadsheet.
So that's essentially the toy
I wanted to share with you.
And the reason I wanted to share
this toy with you is
because I thought it would be a
good opportunity for you to
go later on home and say, how
could I take this data and
tell my story?
And I'd like to motivate you
by showing the story that I
built and my personal story
using this data.
So I'll ask you now to resist
the temptation to keep on
playing with this toy until
the end of the talk.
And listen to the story that
I have to tell you.
OK.
So I don't know if you recognize
the main actor in
this story.
Our UI designers did
an amazing job in
replicating my glasses.
So what I did instead of writing
a name, like you wrote
Dan or David, I use the exact
same tool that I gave you just
a second ago and I just
wrote the word great.
OK, how many times do I have
threads that I sent out that
have the word great?
And you could see that I do not
use the word great lightly
throughout history.
Actually certain months I did
not use the word great at all.
But then in the last three
months, this amazing spike.
OK, listen to this.
In March 2012, so just three
months ago, I used the word
great 34 times.
That's like I write great
every day now.
And the question that you're
probably asking yourselves is,
what happened that made me make
this dramatic shift for
me to start writing great.
And this is the story that I
would like to share with you.
So before we start with our
story, a few other experiments
that I did, I wrote different
words like design, YouTube,
machine learning, brain and
cognition, different topics
that interest me, visualization
and travel.
And then I aggregated, over
time, like Yinnon showed
earlier on, I did that type of
averaging and then I could
have this nice donut.
So you could see that, for
example, traveling I have 58
mentions of traveling.
And what you could see
here in the left hand
side, is you can see--
using the exact same tool
that I showed you
a few minutes ago--
you could see different cities
or countries in the world that
were mentioned in my email
across the last years and you
could see that I've traveled
quite a lot.
And essentially I think that
we started by showing or
describing the protagonist
of the story.
And now let's turn to
the antagonist.
And often an antagonist is just
another character in the
story, the bad guy.
But there are many stories where
the antagonist is not
necessarily another person.
It could be like a force of
nature, you're fighting
against a storm or
something else.
It could be a psychological
force or psychological flaw
that the actor must overcome.
And here I'll be sharing with
you some of my personal flaws.
So please keep it in this room
and let's ignore the fact that
everything is taped and sent
throughout the world.
But I want to give you a
perspective of the different
women that I've had significant
relationships with
in the last few years.
And here you could see my
problem surfacing is that I'm
not able to find the
right woman.
So some of these relationships
are very short.
OK, and some of them
are much longer.
Some of them have a lot of
communications in them like
the one here in green.
Some of them are shallower.
And this will be kind of a
theme that I'm trying to
develop while I'm telling
my story.
So we talked a bit about the
main actor, we talked a bit
about the conflict that he has
to address, and now we want to
establish time.
OK, so we'll be moving back
to the end of 2006.
And at that period of time, I
moved from working in Google
Mountain View to working
back in Israel.
And this was towards the end
of my first marriage.
And I remember coming back to
Israel and drinking a beer
with my good friend Johnny.
And I was kind of lamenting,
Johnny, why don't my
relationships work?
What could be done?
And he told me, Michael, it's
a question of expectations.
He told me the following
thing.
He said, in your league, a girl
could be sane, she could
be pretty, she could be
interesting, she could be fun,
there are a lot of positive
things that
could be around a girl.
But in your league, you'll never
get more than two out of
these four.
That was his expectation.
And he said, if you set that
expectation, things will
gradually improve.
So John is known for his
infinite wisdom.
And I was thinking about my
current relationship, or my
ending relationship with my
first wife, and I said, yeah
she was definitely sane, she
was definitely pretty, but
things were not interesting.
And I understood that she had
two of these characteristics,
but she definitely did not
have four out of four.
So I remember I was back in
university at the time.
And suddenly I met May.
And she was something completely
different, right?
She was pretty, but she
was super interesting.
She was really, really
interesting.
And you can see the surge in
emails that I've started
sending to May.
And on the top here, these are
emails that I've been sending.
What I'd like to show you now
is the number of emails that
I've been receiving.
OK.
So on the top is emails I've
been sending, on the bottom,
emails I've been receiving.
And you could see that my
relationship with Diane, where
it was kind of I would send
an email maybe get an
email back, maybe not.
But with May, I would send an
email and suddenly I would get
like 10 emails back.
And at the beginning I was super
excited about all of
this interest and all
of this attention.
But what started as a lot of
attention became way, way, way
too much very, very soon
and that relationship
didn't last for long.
So I found myself back
in the dating scene.
And using the same tool that you
guys will play around with
later on, I just wrote the
word dating and I got an
aggregation of how many threads
had the word dating.
And you could see that in that
fairly sad period of time I
had points where I would have 51
threads in a certain month
that had the world
dating in them.
And then I would try to
recover from that.
And then probably my all time
high, 79 threads, active
threads, with the word dating
in September, 2007.
And I was like, this
is way too much.
I can't deal with
this anymore.
And I remember one evening I
went on a date, I was sure it
would be yet another date.
And then something truly
amazing happened.
I went on this date
and I met Tammy.
I start talking to her,
I was like, whoa.
She's sane, she's pretty, she's
interesting, she's fun.
And I call Johnny, I was
like, four out of four!
Four out of four, Johnny!
It's amazing, it's happening.
And I was like all
excited by this.
But unfortunately the curse of
the two traits was probably
correct because she called me
two or three days later and
she said, it's not you,
it's me, na-na-na.
And she took off.
So I was heartbroken by this
and I decided to leave
Jerusalem, which is pretty much
like Wyoming in Israel.
I moved to the big town, to Tel
Aviv, which is like New
York, San Francisco.
So I moved to Tel Aviv and
surely, like a day after I
moved to Tel Aviv, I met
my second wife, Lily.
And what was amazing is that we
met online, but although we
met online it turned out--
I asked her, where
do you live?
And it turned out she lives
like three doors away from
where I live in Tel Aviv.
So that was truly amazing.
So you could see here the place
where she lives, here's
where I live, this
was our first
date, here we got married.
We moved into that apartment.
So everything was in a radius
of maybe 100 meters for me.
And I saw this as a sign.
I said, this is a sign.
This is a relationship that
will definitely work.
And I had this resolution, I
will make this relationship a
success no matter what.
That was my resolution
at the time.
And we started, everything
looked good, but in a matter
of two months the first
crisis kicked in.
And we broke up for two
or three weeks,
then we got back again.
And you could see this roller
coaster effect of this
relationship.
And probably the saddest point
in the story is when I said,
you know what?
Maybe the problem is that we're
not living together.
Big mistake, guys.
OK?
So I said, let's move
in together.
Here, come move into
my apartment.
She moved into my apartment
on September of 2008.
What you can see here is that
July, August I've been using
the word love three or four
times a month, I've been using
the word fun.
Now she moves in, love
barely once a month,
fun completely out.
So definitely not a
good move there.
But you remember
my resolution.
This would succeed
no matter what.
So a few months later we
had yet another crisis.
I went down to Sinai to think
about what should I do?
She flew over to Greece to
think what she should do.
And in the third day of thinking
I said, Michael,
remember your resolution.
You have to make this work.
I literally took the first
flight to Greece, found island
where she was hiding, found the
hut, knocked on the door,
and I told her, Lily, I
want you to marry me.
I think we could
make this work.
So I was somewhat over
optimistic at the time.
And we decided to move.
We said, oh maybe the
problem was that she
moved into my apartment.
Let's move into a
joint apartment.
So we moved into a
Some disastrous things happened,
and eventually at a
certain point we broke.
And you could see that after
breaking up I was devastated.
I failed with my resolution
to make this
relationship succeed.
And my mentions of great
go and decline.
I'll keep the story short
because we have to finish in a
few minutes.
But after I was devastated, I
met Anna who was my girlfriend
until just recently.
And again we had sane,
we had fun, a new
combination this time.
Sane and fun.
And I always remembered Johnny
in the back of my mind saying
you have to settle down for two
out of four, you have to
settle down for two
out of four.
Just accept it and everything
will turn out OK.
And then a few months
ago in September, I
suddenly get an email.
I get an email from Tammy.
Four out of four, you
remember that.
The dream, that I thought
could happen once.
And once I got to the end--
she sent me this benign email
like, how are you doing?
Or something like that.
And I thought, maybe
she's interested.
Maybe she--
and ever since I got that email,
I noticed that the
correspondence with Anna, my
current girlfriend kind of
went downhill.
And I said, I have to go
and think about this.
So I flew over to India.
And I don't know if you
can see this but I
flew over to India.
And I said, Michael, you have
to make a decision.
Could you just accept that a
two out of two is what you
should settle for?
Or should you follow your dream
and try to find that
magical four out of four?
So I was thinking, and I was in
India like for a month, and
let me ask you guys, should I
follow my dream or should I
settle for two out of two?
Follow your dream, right?
Of course.
Good choice.
So I came back, and I told
her, listen, I have
to follow my dream.
I'm sorry, it's not you,
it's me, na-na-na.
And I got the guts to call up
Tammy, you remember, the four
out of four, I got the
guts to call her.
And to my surprise, she's
like, yeah sure.
We should go out.
Great!
And two months later, we
moved in together.
I was like, whoa.
This is great.
Everything's working out.
And that's pretty much
the end of the story.
And that's why everything
seems great now.
And I think that with
that we will end.
But just one more second, I
want to I have a serious
summary slide so you think
that this talk
was all about fun.
So we presented two models,
one was focused on data
exploration, the other one was
focused on storytelling.
Data exploration, as Yinnon
explained at the beginning of
this talk, is essentially
looking at the exponential
number of the slices of data
and saying that all of the
legitimate moves that your
controls provide is like one
big graph that the user could
navigate through.
And storytelling on the other
hand, is you making a very
careful decision on what slices
of data do you want to
show and in what sequence and
in what tempo do you want to
show them in order to emphasize
a certain point.
So one is has exponential
components, the other one has
linear components.
One provides an unbiased
point of view.
Here's a dashboard.
Go explore the data.
The other one has a certain
agenda that you
could use to promote.
One has the user required to
engage with the controls and
know what he's doing.
On the other one the user has
the advantage and disadvantage
of being passive.
The response to dashboards,
your users are often
overwhelmed.
While story could gauge interest
and walk the user
through the data that you
might be interested in.
One last thought that I want to
share before concluding is
that these two models are not
necessarily mutually exclusive.
So what you could do--
and one of the big advantages
that Google Chart Tools
provides both of these models
in one unified framework--
is that you could say, let me
start by exposing the data via
story, get the user engaged.
Instead of just giving him a
dashboard interface, let me
show him through a story.
But then at any given time or
maybe at the end of the story,
let the user get the power
to say, oh do you
remember that scene?
I wonder what happened a bit
before or a bit after?
And suddenly you could build
an interface that easily
transitions between these
two frameworks-- between
storytelling, and between
data exploration.
Thank you.
Technical questions for Yinnon
or other questions to me?
Thanks, we're here for the
next 20 minutes if you
want to grab us.
Thank you.